un mari de calmer bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin
alors il s'agit de la plus grosse amende
jamais ordonné par le juge administratif
c'est un symbole fort contre l'inaction
étatique
bonjour alors effectivement il s'agit
d'une somme historique
ce que nous espérons c'est que ça
provoque un déclic en fait notamment
dans l'opinion publique mais aussi
auprès de nos politiques qui doivent se
rendre compte de l'urgence d'agir pour
leur rappeler en fait il s'agit
néanmoins de 11 ans dans lesquels la
france c'est complet dans ce système
d'illégalité puisqu'elle avait
l'obligation de respecter ces normes
depuis 2010 et aujourd'hui on parle de
environ soixante sept mille décès par an
donc enfin compte c'est évident que
cette liquidation en fait de cette
astreinte à agir
elle est plus que bienvenu elle pourrait
d'ailleurs se renouveler dans six mois
et nous espérons que ça provoque un
effet fort dans l'opinion publique et
auprès des politiques pour les inciter
enfin à agir quand vous dites enfin agir
c'est de mettre en place des politiques
justement structurantes pour pour lutter
contre la pollution de l'air notamment
oui tout à fait en fait depuis de
nombreuses années l'état sait
pertinemment ce qui doit être fait pour
réduire les émissions notamment de
particules fines qui sont
particulièrement dangereuses pour la
santé
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas uniquement ce ne
sont pas uniquement les militants qu'il
aurait calmé même la cour des comptes
avait sorti un rapport l'an 2019
pointant le manque de mesures mis en
place par l'état et évoquant notamment
les risques financiers pour l'état
justement du fait des actions juridiques
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui la cour des
comptes estime que l'état se met en
danger d'être sanctionnées notamment par
ses propres institutions comme c'est le
cas actuellement mais aussi par les
institutions européennes
on parle de 100 millions d'euros qui
pourraient également être appliquée par
la cour de justice de l'union européenne
la france pour non respect des normes en
matière de pollution atmosphérique et
donc c'est évidemment un énorme jeu
risques juridiques et financiers que la
cour des comptes pointe et pour cela
elle a évoqué une douzaine de mesures
dont notamment évidemment les mesures en
matière de régulation du trafic mais
aussi en matière de réglementation des
pratiques agricoles qui ont également
une large part de responsabilité dans la
pollution de l'air alors on entend bien
que vous souhaitez de des politiques
fortes pour lutter justement contre la
pollution mais on le voit bien on l'a
d'ailleurs dit la commission européenne
la cour des comptes l'état était pointé
plusieurs fois que ça soit au niveau
européen au niveau français est
finalement rien n'a été fait et y at il
d'autres moyens pour pousser justement
le gouvernement à agir
et bien c'est ça qui est malheureux
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les 10
millions d'euros d'astreinte qui ont été
donc alloué finalement à d'autres
instances publiques c'est à dire que la
justice constate la carence de l'état
son incapacité à agir et un loup des
sommes à d'autres institutions publiques
et à des associations pour pouvoir mieux
contrôler justement les mesures mis en
place par l'état
personnellement je trouve ça extrêmement
grave
d'une part parce que question de nous
sur la somme 10 millions d'euros pour
vos données 1 1 une échelle ça
représente le coût de construction d'un
collège en france et donc c'est pas
grand chose finalement
par rapport à l'étendue évidemment des
mesures qui devraient être mis en place
par l'état
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui les sommes
allouées par l'état pour la protection
de l'air elles sont minimes par rapport
aux sommes investies dans des réductions
de taxes de fiscalité qui incitent à la
consommation de produits polluants on
est donc vraiment dans un cul-de-sac
si on continue comme on le fait
aujourd'hui il faut profondément revoir
nos politiques publiques et
malheureusement mont-royal ce
gouvernement a en a été totalement
incapable justement 10 millions d'euros
qui est
qui devront être partagés entre
plusieurs bénéficiaires des
établissements publics des structures
agréées de surveillance de la qualité de
l'air dans les zones concernées
vous parlez d'une somme minime quand on
est évidemment on partage ce montant
qu'est ce qu'il est possible de faire
concrètement avec ses 10 millions
d'euros c'est pour le moment en tout cas
ce qui est encourageant c'est que des
sommes soient alloués notamment aux
associations comme airparif qui se
consacre à l'analyse des données qui
sont fournis justement et qui sont
collectées sur le terrain ça permet
d'avoir une meilleure visibilité sur
l'efficacité des mesures mises en place
mais ça ne remplacera absolument pas
l'effort qui doit être fait par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui personne ne
peut se substituer et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas souhaitable que nous
renoncions à une action des politiques
publiques il faut les forcer à agir dans
les urnes dans la rue et c'est bien ce
que font les associations maintenant
aussi dans les tribunaux pour évidemment
avoir des politiques publiques qui
soient à la hauteur des enjeux
on peut pas se satisfaire de la décision
qui a été prise aujourd'hui je rappelle
qu'il s'agit justement de la liquidation
d'une astreinte donc qui doit
contraindre l'état à agir
il ne s'agit même pas d'une action en
responsabilité pour indemniser tous ces
dizaines de milliers de victimes par an
qui dont les familles sont directement
impactés par leur décès précoce et on
pourrait d'ailleurs imaginer à terme que
justement ces victimes ces familles de
victimes se retourne elle aussi contre
l'état puisque il faut le rappeler se
sont quand même nos vies qui sont en jeu
dans cette situation merci beaucoup en
tout cas marine calme et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de l'association
wild les galas